Одні  не можуть вилетіти…
Затримки якісь незрозумілі.
Інші, радіють, що нарешті повернулися додому.
Ми замість 6-7 днів пробули 10.
Сезон відпусток щойно почався, а відпочинок багатьох українців
уже зіпсований. Через конфлікт між деякими
туроператорами та їхніми авіаперевізниками
вильоти або затримуються, або їх переносять
до іншого аеропорту чи навіть міста.
А деякі рейси взагалі скасовують.
На літак додому харків’янка Ірина чекала в Тунісі 4 доби.
Виселяли. Ми не знали, господар готелю кричить:
я не буду займатись благодійністю, зараз всі підете
під паркан, з дітками маленькими. Це взагалі відпустка, як ви вважаєте?
Це чотири дні суцільних нервувань.
Конфлікт почався ще на початку літа.
Тоді туристи скаржились на затримку рейсів від 12 годин до доби.
Туроператори не виходили на зв’язок.
А коли врешті відповідали, то всю провину перекладали на перевізника.
Мовляв, він піднімає в небо старі літаки,
вони ламаються, а поки триває ремонт,
рейси доводиться відкладати. При цьому сам туроператор, схоже,
не цікавить, якими літаками відправляє своїх клієнтів на відпочинок.
У нас є контракт із авіакомпанією, яка регламентує
за даним договором здійснення послуги -
авіаперевезення з певною кількістю крісел,
а тип повітряного судна там не регламентується.
Згодом виник і фінансовий конфлікт.
У гарячий літній сезон Авіакомпанія "Браво",
яка обслуговує чимало туроператорів, серед них і Join UP,
заявила, що OASIS Travel Ukraine за два роки
заборгував їй 1 мільйон доларів.
Представники авіаперевізника кажуть, що чекали грошового переказу.
Утім, борг тільки зростав, тож аби не літати у збиток,
вирішили скасувати рейси за напрямком цього туроператора.
Понад півтори тисячі українців не могли повернутися додому
з Тунісу, Чорногорії та Албанії.
У ситуацію втрутилися чиновники з Мінінфраструктури.
Обіцяють, що будуть забирати ліцензії в недобросовісних туроператорів
та посилять контроль над авіаперевізниками.
А саме - перевірять вік та якість літаків.
У компанії "Браво", наприклад, із 5-ти бортів трьом - понад 25 років.
Ми хочемо не лише
встановити верхню межу по віку літаків,
ми хочемо спільно з авіакомпаніями, які працюють на українському ринку,
розробити пільгову лізингову програму
з залученням державних банків
для того, щоб флот можна було оновлювати швидше і якісніше.
Поки туристам радять подавати колективні позови в суди
на туроператорів та перевізників. А також перед купівлею путівки
вивчати відгуки про туроператорів та умови контракту.
Утім, багато хто, як Олена, вибирає оператора,
виходячи з ціни мандрівки.
Люди платять немаленькі гроші,
вони працюють весь рік для того, щоб
тиждень цей
відпочити гарно,
насолодитися і не з такими нервами їхати.
Але коли вже ти тут знервований і цю добу витрачаєш на те,
щоб добратись на якісь переноси рейсів,
вже відчуття відпочинку, звичайно, псується.
Олена з донькою вже із затримкою полетіла в Туреччину.
А якщо і повенутися вчасно не вдасться,
жінка не збирається пробачати туроператорм зіпсовану відпустку
та обіцяє судитися.